[Music]
[Applause]
okay whenever city
that's why I don't wear sunglasses big
story North Korea is celebrating the
one-year anniversary of kim jong un's
ascension to power yeah that's right
that's right one year ago today Kim
jong-un ascended to power by climbing
onto a phone book that was the ceremony
he got
now they're up to something today true
story North Korea raised a missile to an
upright position
then later tucked it back into its
launcher North Korea did all this after
its wife went to bed
it just sounds creepy who's watching the
Masters anybody watching the Masters all
right thank you sir
this year one guy yes
this year a 14 year old boy from China
is the youngest golfer to ever compete
in the Masters yeah youngest yeah okay
well yeah during his round of golf today
the Chinese boy made two birdies an
eagle and an iPad
why am I doing this I'm making a Stone
Age iPad I have a basic misunderstanding
of high technology I'm not good at that
stuff nASA has big plans nASA has
announced a plan to lasso an asteroid
and bring it closer to Earth this is
according to the head of NASA a
six-year-old boy they really want to do
that that's a real plan that I bring it
closer I don't know oh yeah I don't know
I have no idea we just tell jokes we
don't tell the news yeah we don't read
the whole paper we just read the part
that can help us with the jokes on
Tuesday at the White House President
Obama sang with Justin Timberlake yeah
it's being called the blackest thing
President Obama has ever done
[Applause]
decently have any comic fans here
DC Comics DC Comics has introduced its
first ever transgender character yeah
the character is called wonder if it's a
woman
[Applause]
turn around again
crazy story in Maine a hermit living in
the woods was arrested he claims he's
only seen one human since 1986 now but
he's telling the truth because for his
one phone call he tried to reach mr.
Belvedere you saved it sir thank you do
you even know who mr. Belvedere is no
you have no idea I I think I know why
he's wearing sunglasses
this is really happening man listen to
this one gang Stephen Hawking the
scientist and the brilliant man Stephen
Hawking said that unless we find a way
to escape earth human beings will not
survive this current millennium yeah
yeah
Hawking made the prediction at what
turned out to be an incredibly
depressing baby shower totally total
buzzkill for everybody except this guy
[Laughter]
here in Hollywood and actress is suing a
website for revealing her actual age
however the lawsuit will be dropped if
TMZ apologizes to 33 year-old Betty
White
you